heartland daily
gender activists push to bar
anthropologists from identifying human
remains as male or female okay this is
where we're at now
i'm telling you your slippery slope is
like a slip and slide down do you see
this now
this is where the gender debate goes now
that the now the anthropologists can't
do their job because it's offensive to
somebody i mean do you really am i still
is this happening for real or am i in
some type of alternate underworld
where this is going on
let's read shall we
a new school of thought within
archaeology is pushing scientists to
think twice about assigning gender to
ancient human remains can you i just
can't even
it is possible to determine whether a
skeleton is from a biological male or
female using objective observations of
course it is
of course it is
based on the size and shape of bones
criminal forensic detectives for example
do it frequently in their line of work
so is that next are the criminal
forensic detectives not going to be able
to properly identify human remains
where is this going that that works out
in a beneficial way for society
this lack of facts and attention to
facts
gender activists argue scientists cannot
know how an ancient individual
identified themselves well let me tell
you ancient individuals weren't thinking
about stuff like this they were thinking
about survival
they were thinking about survival they
weren't sitting around the table
hunting and gathering and saying well
how do you identify
that is a conversation that happens
among the privileged
okay let's be real
this is this the article's too good
we're going to go on university of
kansas associate professor jennifer raff
suggested scientists cannot know the
gender of a 9 000 year old biologically
peruvian hunter because they don't know
whether the hunter identified as male or
female
a duality concept she says was imposed
by christian colonizers i i mean
she thinks i mean let's get this woman
to sit here she thinks that a 9 000 year
old peruvian hunter
was sitting around contemplating their
gender identity
can you make stuff up that's more
batshit crazy than this
please i invite you put it in the chat
you got something crazier than this put
it in the chat i'll cover it
now what's interesting here i found in
the second page there was a professor
professor elizabeth weiss and this is
important to me she weighed in and she
noted that applying biological sex to
remains often helps dispel myths
detrimental
to women this is interesting some early
anthropologists sometimes mistook some
robust female skeletons as male
skeletons particularly in these certain
collections this reinforced false
stereotypes that females were not as
hard working as males
so all i saw that and i said
again you got women getting the short
end of the stick in this situation
because you can't call a man a man and a
woman a woman who seems to be suffering
the most these biological women now they
can't even get proper credit for the way
they lived for the way they worked for
the for the duties they performed
successfully back x amount of years ago
fast forward to 2022 when people are
taking their honors woman of the year
taking their trophies
taking the privilege of breastfeeding
turning into chess feeding all this
nonsense are you awake yet ladies
honestly are you awake i know you you
may be expecting somebody else to lead
this charge but it's going to be you
you in this conversation women are
getting the short end of the stick over
and over and over and over again and
there's a passivity that i see in women
with respect to this i don't know if
you're afraid i don't i don't know what
it is it can't be you can't be that
worried about getting cancelled
everybody and their mother gets canceled
it's almost like a badge of honor now if
you don't get cancelled it just means
you're not saying anything important
so wake up speak up
you see this i mean this is where it's
going this is no longer we can no longer
act like this is just a live and let
live discussion because the crazies are
taking over
okay and it's happening at high levels
of the biden administration
we did a video the other day of rachel
levine talking about the puberty
blockers and normalizing all of these
things for children
okay so this is a serious time
it requires serious vocal people
women lead the charge if you don't don't
expect somebody else to and then suffer
the consequences
you know if you read the writing on the
wall we are headed towards a collapse
one of the things i'm not a historian
but one of the things you hear about
often is that before civilizations
collapse they become obsessed with sex
race ethnicity
trans just like so camille pagalia who
uh i i don't know if i'm saying her last
name right i think she's brilliant i
don't agree with everything she says but
very smart lady gave a talk lesson from
history transgender mania is a sign of
cultural collapse she argues that from
the greeks to the romans to now that
homosexuality gender fluidity etc are
what a culture ends up becoming right
before its downfall the downfall is
brought on by cultures around
that are more rigid in gender roles and
it's like we we are becoming so obsessed
with this nonsense it's like you said
the other day the military isn't
prepared we're not prepared people
aren't prepared they don't know what's
going on around them they don't
understand things and it's
it really does feel like like we're
headed towards the collapse the question
i think really becomes is it is it
intentional though
because if it's not i mean you would
have to be so profoundly inept
it's too
organized it's too the message is
there's too much collusion collusion in
the messaging now we're talking about
eating bugs and people are increasingly
becoming more and more unhealthy it's at
every level of society and we've been
covering every aspect of that whether
it's the covered mania and having people
not look at each other in the eye
anymore whether it's eating bugs whether
it's you know you're a racist you're a
homophobe you're a bigot without even
having a conversation with somebody
anymore awoke military you add all this
together
it looks like there's a strategy here is
all i'm saying and again i'm not a
conspiracy theorist but if you wanted to
i ask you again and i'm going to ask you
over and over again
if you wanted to actively destroy a
country what would you do differently
not much
so if you are invested in this country
if you're invested and if you want a
healthy happy
safe family if you're invested in your
own health if you're invested in your
children's education if you're invested
in a common and shared humanity and
respectful discourse if you're invested
in facts
and you want things like male and female
to not become you know subjective
floating clouds in the sky
speak up
it's now or never speak up talk to get
into you know little groups in your
community have those discussions you are
an empowered citizen you don't have to
lie down and take all this if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]